SPEAKER: The cloud
has many benefits.
It gives you a platform for
more dynamic decision-making.
It helps accelerate innovation.
And it has the potential for
significant cost efficiencies.
To realize that potential,
you need the right tools
to help you build a path to
more predictable cloud costs.
With Google Cloud's
cost management tools,
you can gain the visibility,
accountability, control,
and intelligence you need to
achieve greater predictability
and cost efficiencies
in the cloud.
Designed for organizations
of all sizes,
these tools make it easy to see
your current and future costs
with built-in reporting and
customizable dashboards.
Not only can you see your costs,
you can increase accountability
for them by allocating costs to
specific departments and teams
within your
organization, meaning
you can truly understand
the return on your cloud
investment.
You can also control
who can do the spending
with easily configurable
policies and permissions.
These strong
financial governance
controls help you more
effectively plan and reduce
the risk of overspending.
And you can stay smart
about your spending
with intelligent
recommendations tailored
to your business that help
further optimize your usage
while minimizing costs.
Google Cloud cost
management, the path
to predictable cloud costs.